I think 50 Cent's problem was that he
was he's just too jacked I think his
bicep got really got in the way there
gotta have a low Mobility if you're
gonna throw
so he probably has both problems he's
his clothes are tight and then he also
is jacked as well oh this one's the best
I've seen this one oh my God it's like
he aimed for it that's my favorite one
by far all right let's see this one oh
he just held on to it too long I think
that's a good arm that's a good arm
stroke yeah he just held on to it too
long what am I watching here so he
played baseball so this has to be I've
never seen this before Oh Michael yeah I
didn't expect that you know he he played
played professional baseball oh here's
Barack President Obama now he he likes
baseball he was good oh okay yeah not
great either